joining me here is one of my favorites
and i would say that even if he wasn't
on hold hearing me introduce him on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line
uh his green light podcast is very very
popular and i always enjoy his takes his
opinions he's chris long back here on
the rich eisen show how are you chris
rich i'm good i thought you were
buttering me up to tell me how much my
success intake uh was terrible it was uh
because i came around on it last night
you know what it's funny that uh that
you bring that up first i was gonna
bring it up last but i'll i'll i'll bite
um succession is one of the best
television shows i've ever seen
and uh it took me a couple of episodes
of season one to get into it where
exactly you know the first couple
episodes of season one my wife and i are
looking at each other like why are we
spending an hour with people that are
just so uncomfortable
right like who do i root for i don't
root for anybody then i think it was
like episode three or four it was like a
rocket ship that kept going straight up
uh through the stratosphere and it got
so good and it's still that way it's
this past season that just finished and
i won't do any spoilers here
spectacular it's like one episode after
another is an opus but
you it took you until just now i hate it
no i hated it for 90 minutes i had to
get through the first 90 minutes as you
kind of put it i'm like way behind oh so
you are okay so this is not a current
season situation yeah my co-host making
shout out was like he turned me on to
white lotus which i thought i'd hate i
loved it okay um he turned me on to
succession now so i just started it and
i just thought the first 90 minutes the
characters were just so eager to over
develop themselves and avoid the hell
out of me correct and then and then all
of a sudden kind of like you said
you know last night it clicked
and i admitted on twitter yes that uh i
no longer hate succession i'm done
hating success and i'm into it so i'm
excited to see the next couple seasons i
am now officially jealous of you because
the show is truly chris i've never seen
a show where the last show actually that
that got so good from episode to episode
uh was breaking bad that's how that was
the last one that was just like oh god
that was incredible and the next one was
like that is a classic that's an nc
classic and and and no dramatic show
supposedly makes me laugh out loud more
than succession
laugh out loud
i'll admit it it's pretty good so
um welcome you got hey you got bert in
studio today i'm pretty sure
i do bert crusher coming here yeah oh my
gosh yeah shirt's off man that's a
legend shirt's off hour number three not
mine but you know
just trying to give everybody what they
want which is more bird christian so uh
let's just jump into this right here uh
chris with what's going on in cleveland
and kovid 19 do you think would players
want to would you want to play this game
would you want it canceled push back
what would you what do you think players
are thinking about right now man listen
i gambled on a game last year with the
wake forest
uh quarterback uh who was like a wide
receiver the hinton game the hinton
tastes still game correct i actually had
to stick it out and and i bet that game
on a wednesday and had to stick it out
and watch it
i don't feel bad for anybody get
creative win football games this is this
is entertaining to me i hate the covid
part of it but i am interested to see
you know what teams are the most
malleable which teams have solutions to
these problems uh who can hit the curve
ball the best because
you know we all signed up for this um
you know over these few years and we'll
see how long this stuff lasts uh but the
reality that you're dealt and uh yeah i
mean we didn't bend for that last year i
lost a few hundred bucks i don't feel
sorry for anybody now so what what about
if you go back to the days where you're
playing you're sitting in this locker
room you have the same sense obviously
you're not laying anything other than
yours i'm not i'm really not sure how
i'd feel um
the way i'd probably feel though uh is
that like i gotta control the
controllables which is like i haven't
heard anything about that they're
considering pushing a game back or
anything like that uh but i also decided
this week that i wasn't gonna ride the
covid wave and
and keep up with every inactive i saw a
list yesterday
um that was like 40 names long and right
i think that's the big thing that people
didn't think about is like eventually it
gets cold people hang out inside more
and the transmissibility goes up and
we're going to be dealing with this like
we we thought we were out of the woods
and we're just not not from a standpoint
of how the nfl's operated with this
thing chris long two-time super bowl
champion here on the rich eisen show all
right so then put yourself in the locker
room in jacksonville what do you think
the players are thinking there
right now oh get me out of here i mean
like you got to be kidding me i like
if the things is again because i'm you
know unnamed sources and that sort of
thing but when there's enough smoke
there's fire when there's a football
emergency i think sometimes these
unnamed sources can be
can be useful i yeah i've been on a lot
of bad teams i've been on teams multiple
times worse than this jacksonville team
they have a couple good players on the
team they've been competitive you know
they you know they beat buffalo they've
played people tough
at times
but i think they're poorly coached
football team on the surface and the
culture is terrible right now and it
starts with one guy
um you know the thing that i heard he
was running those assistant coaches
through the ringer is ridiculous because
the irony is
it's like giving mike rabel the dead
fish handshake
i am team bravel all the way and i know
they work together
uh in college right
like it's almost like urban forgets that
he's not that guy in the pros
like this is you're not that dude here
you know like mike frable's that dude
here like you gotta start showing some
respect for the game and respect for the
guys that are busting their asses and
putting their their livelihoods on the
line and their health online for a guy
that's you know just cultivated an
incredibly toxic environment it sounds
like it's almost like he's throwing the
game and i don't mean the games i mean
he's throwing
the game when it comes to his employment
with the jacksonville jaguars so
as a player i've been on worst teams but
i've never had a guy running the show
that did anything like this and that
makes it really a tough pill to swallow
being on team like that wow so i mean
because my my reaction to it is that we
were all wondering how's urban gonna
handle the losing because he lost only
nine times at ohio state nine that's you
wondered that well no well i mean yeah i
wondered how will he cause because if
you're taking a job in the nfl choosing
first overall no matter how
generationally talented you know
uh lawrence is you know trevor lawrence
is so terrific but you know how i mean
everyone knows everyone watches football
in that regard so knows that there is
going to be more losing potentially in
the first year than you had in an entire
tenure at ohio state so kind of have to
slow your roll when it comes to that but
instead it appears he employs the only
thing that he knows would when he loses
once every two years like he did at the
other college level and when you do that
over and over and over again it doesn't
work in the nfl so and and and the thing
that kind of hit me too chris is that he
was like yeah he's not used to people
talking i mean welcome the nfl i mean
well that's the thing it's like you know
i mean really ask yourself do you think
urban meyer ran these equations in his
head he's the guy who's used to winning
he expects that he's going to win he
expects that he's going to be successful
um you know to a fault and over that
line by a wide margin so
i don't know man for for me it's it's
it's disappointing because i do think
there should be a standard of like
workplace culture for nfl players we put
a lot on the line
and uh it's a tough hand to be dealt
like the average career is three four
years
if you're a great player you play 10 11
12 13 14 years i mean like every year
adds up and you're and and your
marketability to other teams as far as
being
you know individually
you know uh successful in free agency or
whatever like that tape doesn't go away
and if you're playing
in a circumstance like that
schematically or culturally it's a
terrible waste of time and i just feel
bad for those guys
but i don't think he thought through the
possibility of him like losing i don't
think that's that's really an equation
that goes on in that guy's head and have
you ever been on a field where a player
comes up to you says get me out of here
you have no idea what just happened on
the sideline of my team oh for sure but
a lot of that a lot of times it's like a
dysfunctional relationship with a
position coach or like there's a
dysfunctional um situation with with the
gm or something like that
you know the head coach to be so widely
kind of like what the heck is he doing i
mean from the james robinson thing to
the disagreement he's had with with the
receiver room
to the whole debacle coming home early
in the season um
yeah it's it's it's ugly man and and
it's not baseball it's not basketball
it's not like man this is going to suck
to run around for 82 games or
you know like i got to travel with this
guy for the year like we're putting our
livelihoods on the line and our health
on the line and i think there needs to
be like a standard for
for how the workplace is is uh operating
in the nfl what do you mean by that
standard well i mean this is this is i
mean i can't cuss on your show but it's
bs
you know some of the things that that
are happening down there are true it's
it's a huge waste of time it's uh
you can't get that time back every snap
in the nfl is more important than than
in other sports i mean uh
you know the average careers are shorter
and you waste a year in the nfl that
could be that's career altering and guys
are wasting time down there
chris long here uh on the rich eisen
show so uh the you know news out of
arizona now is that uh deandre hopkins
getting a second opinion on on a knee
injury from
the loss to the rams and uh james
connors now day to day with a knee
injury potentially even worse than that
it seems like arizona had a more than
just a loss on on monday night um or um
it's just a week in the nfl well how do
you suss out the nfc right now through
14 weeks chris long i mean i think the
green bay packers are the best team in
the nfc and the bucks are right there um
i i think those two teams are the class
of the nfc uh
i think that's becoming more apparent
you know even with kyler and arizona
playing their best i just you know like
the the variability in how healthy he
might be now i think cliff and those
guys did a good job of resting him this
time around last year he had that
shoulder injury that lingered for a
while and so it changed the style of
football they played it was obvious to
me when he came back against chicago
that he was they were willing to allow
him to make plays with his legs so i
think he's healthy i think that's a
positive they handled that well
but you know when it comes to that
division and the rams like the rams have
had a little time to figure out the
robert woods loss mcveigh's been kind of
under the the hot lamp a little bit and
that's uncharacteristic
um you know i think they're figuring
some things out and i i do think when
everybody scoffed at like joe buck and
troy aikman that they're caping for
for matt stafford talking about how hurt
he is like i really do think he was hurt
and i do think he might still be hurt
and getting healthy i mean like uh
and he looked good the other night so
it's a good sign for the rams but i
don't take too much from that game they
they created turnovers um they had
created a turnover in the red area you
had a fourth and two drop by d-hop which
is last time that happened in 2019 in
the red area
uh they had another
uh a pick
so you know that ball he was trying to
float to earth's and and floyd made a
great play like they left a lot of
points on the field so this team these
teams are going to see each other again
i think sometimes in the nfl and with
the media we get so we overreact to
every game so much like they played two
games they went totally differently uh
these games are played like in a vacuum
a lot a lot of times like little things
can happen early in the ball game
um like not getting points in the red
zone or throwing that pick early that
changed the entire game so they'll see
each other again i i think as you look
at that playoff picture it's tracking
that way and i want to ask you about the
cowboys in my opinion sitting here um
you know i don't say these words lightly
um dak is definitely in a slump as jerry
jones essentially said on his radio show
this week and the offense and how
healthy they are and it does concern me
but it can be more than made up for
because of number 11 who i think may be
the most special rookie at the position
since lawrence taylor i i wonder what
you think of when you see micah parsons
well i never like sat there in real time
and watched lawrence taylor like
so you know i'm always careful because
there's one comparison you're like we
don't compare people to lt and i'm not
i'm not saying you i'm afraid to do it
um but
i you know like you saw lt play and if
you're saying that like you saw it
happen in real time micah parsons is
incredible i mean he's an absolute alien
man like to be able to do what he does
i've never seen a player that's a
natural here's the deal like natural
pass rusher not just a guy who ad rushes
well that you can move around like
that's going to be quick and athletic
and and hit the b gap on on a pressure
that you've schemed up for him and he's
a great finisher he's all those things
and he has pass rush ability so like
this guy is a total at x factor i had
aaron donald on my pod this morning uh
plugging the green light pod um and he
called him a cheat code and that's
exactly what he is to me like when you
can move a guy around who's that
dominant who on thursday night playing
the saints can run with a slot receiver
down the left sideline and break a ball
up that's you know he's six yards out of
phase
it's ridiculous um and he you know i was
skeptical about the dpoi thing but he's
definitely in the running i agree yeah i
don't recall seeing lt in coverage like
what parsons is doing and and lt was a
natural pass rusher like you could
totally you could tell that like right
from the beginning like this guy was put
on the planet to wreak havoc and make
people frightened pre-snapped totally
you know and
that's what i'm seeing from parsons is
what i'm seeing right now
from him
a cheat code when aaron donald calls him
a cheat code that is uh that's saying
quite a bit
right there
that's coming up on your next podcast
when does that drop the green light
podcast that's out this morning this
morning
you do it you do it you post you're just
and you're moving on that's how you're
rolling i love it yeah you know it's
it's a 24-hour rule
you're enjoying it chris you enjoyed it
yeah we're enjoying the win we had aaron
donald on the day bill simmons and then
and then and then we move on you know
it's a 24-hour rule okay you know i'll
come on too chris i don't know if you're
rich if i'm green light worthy or you
know who i got
i got somebody from michigan coming up
who's that what do you got
i do it might be a pass rusher is it
aiden oh that kid's really special dude
oh so we'll talk about rich eisen
yes that should be the first thing you
talk about yeah not his dad
not his dad not ohio state
not the big charles what's it a rich
isaac which foot yeah yeah just start
start start bench your cut yeah me me
him and brady put him in there
see how i see how i do see how i do good
put throw desmond in bro why not yeah
any time please i'd love to i'd love to
uh reciprocate last one for you what
you're seeing out of new england um is
what chris
what do you got for me defense their
defense is so ball aware they don't play
as much man as they used to uh being
able to generate pass rush with judon
and bar more like hitting on draft picks
hitting on free agents uh hitting on you
know running backs in the draft like
stevenson's great um and just like being
willing to being new england being
willing to do whatever it takes to win
any given week okay you know um and this
week is going to be the one week for me
where i think i actually like the colts
uh but that's if carson can manage not
to do those carson's not a volume
interception thrower okay like i don't
care what anybody says the one year was
terrible what he is is when he throws a
pick he throws it all the way so as long
as he doesn't go all the way
uh a couple times this weekend and i
think like i bet you bill's gonna try to
make carson beat them i think this is a
really tough matchup for new england um
that run game has been a little bit of
an issue from them and that their floor
was kind of exposed and it's a good
floor to have because they won by two
three touchdowns but against tennessee
titans a few weeks ago they really ran
the football i'm sure indy's looking at
that tape it's going to be a really good
football game look forward to it i guess
going full circle uh say hi to logan roy
that's if that's howie's logan
um who are you what what's the long
family in succession if you want to
divvy it up
i don't know but my favorite character
is tom you've nailed it sir
how many episodes are you interested as
hell dude i don't know if we need to say
anymore how many episodes are you in
really i'm three episodes
and already you have identified okay
taking the tree shaking
greg he and greg the conversations
between he and greg
are laughs
loud hilarious it is
just the greatest you're yes sir i am so
jealous of you but you have pegged you
have pegged you you've gotten it right
that you finally came around and tom
wamsgans is your favorite wait till wait
till this oh god don't say anymore no no
no spoiler no no the rest of season one
is just uh a delight certainly when it
comes to him and then and then beyond
thanks the call chris
thank you richard you got it green light
podcast everybody hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here